in our previous lessons We performed a
simplified version of the rna-seq using
the T by info platform but did you know
that it is also possible to perform
differential gene expression analysis at
the end of the standard rnec pipeline
you will explore this briefly in this
video note that in this demo pipeline we
are making use of samples that were
taken from humanized mice with implanted
tumors and our aim here is to First
generate gene expression tables from the
raw RNA secrets and perform differential
gene expression analysis now let us
click on the start to build a pipeline
the steps remain the same as we have
covered in a previous video first we
have the pre-processing step that makes
use of trinomatic
and PCR clean
and note that the functions of each of
the algorithms have been explained in
the pop-ups that show when you click on
that particular step so feel free to
browse through and learn at your own
pace
so for now let's click on bow tie2t
algorithm for mapping on the transcripts
and are some expression table for
quantifying Gene and isoform abundances
and finally let's click on the desect2
option for differential gene expression
analysis
and then click on end
and with that the pipeline is ready we
have performed the differential gene
expression analysis within a standard
rnac pipeline in our next video we will
discuss what are the various outputs and
how to interpret them